und so hier sieht es nach einer
kaminexplosion aus passiert in Erftstadt
das Haus seitdem in Schutt und Asche ein
Familienvater macht hier seinen
Holzkamin an aber scheinbar ist ein
Ventil nicht richtig geöffnet es kommt
tatsächlich zur Verpuffung die Folge
eine riesige Druckwelle der Kamin
explodiert die Rohre bersten die Fenster
springen auf die Türen fliegen aus den
Zargen das Haus ist bis ins Dachgeschoss
beschädigt überall Ruß Risse überall in
den Decken das Wunder der Vater überlebt
wird nur leicht verletzt und das obwohl
die Überlebenschance bei solchen
Unfällen gerade mal bei 10% liegt Frau
und Tochter ebenfalls unverletzt
unfassbar also plötzlich explodierter
ein Kamin in einem Familienhaus und der
Familienvater dem genau das passiert ist
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet Markus beige
sein Haus seitdem in Schutt und Asche
herbeige wie geht es Ihnen und Ihrer
Familie vor allem zuallererst
ja guten Morgen ja unsere Familie geht
natürlich nach einer Woche wo es
passiert ist sehr gut wir sind bei sehr
guten Freunden untergebracht sind
natürlich ist auf der Suche nach einer
neuen Bleibe bis dahin schon einige
gemeldet ja unsere Tochter ist natürlich
noch ein bisschen ja eine Woche nicht in
die Schule gegangen das ist so auf das
Haus gefreut das haben wir gerade auch
erst vor drei vier Tagen bezogen wir
sind jetzt von meiner Switzer nach
Erftstadt Riesa angezogen das Haus hat
uns von Anfang an sehr gut gefallen ja
am Sonntag
war es halt ein bisschen frischer
geworden dann auf den anderen gesagt
komm wir machen einen Termin an der auch
vorher vom Schornsteinfeger abgenommen
worden ist und ja nach einer halben
Stunde vorher an war langsam zu
geräuschlos und ist dann stark dass wir
das Holz was halt der arbeitet und dann
ist meine Frau mit dem Hund hochgegangen
ja und zehn Minuten später gab es dann
halt diese Riesen Verpuffung
ich bin direkt rausgerannt auf dem Boden
der Vermieter der Sohn der kam direkt an
hat die Feuerwehr gerufen meine Tochter
hat die Feuerwehr gerufen meine Frau hat
wohl nach mir berufen aber ich habe
nichts gehört dann paar Minuten statt
die Feuerwehr hier und ja das ging dann
so schnell ins Krankenhaus gefahren
worden und
nach zwei drei Stunden kam ich da wieder
zurück und danach habe ich erst die
ganzen Skizze Ausmaß gesehen da war ich
noch gar nicht die zweite Etage
hochgefahren und dann sagte mir halt
dass das Dachfenster rausgebrochen ist
ja Risse in den Wänden und ja der
Kriminalbeamte sagte Krankenwagen gut
dass keiner im Wohnzimmer war aber da
muss ich ihm leider nicht sprechen sag
ich saß drei Meter davor dann kam halt
erstmal gar nichts und dann sagt er laut
Erfahrungen sind die überlegungschancen
bei sowas bei 10%, ja aber so richtig
begreifen ja aber versucht hat zu
funktionieren
wir arbeiten gehen aber beim Arzt hatte
ich erstmal geschrieben
oder nicht verantworten bei der Frau
sitzt der Schock auch noch sehr tief
naja aber egal wir sind bei sehr guten
Freunden aufgehoben den auch sehr sehr
dankbar sind und
ja hoffen jetzt natürlich darauf dass
jetzt
wohnungsanfragen kommen also nur auf
jeden Fall schnell wirklich wieder
woanders hinziehen weil dieses Haus ist
erstmal ja unbewohnbar Herr Wege sie
haben unglaubliches Glück gehabt dass
Ihnen und Ihrer Familie nichts passiert
ist sie stehen jetzt in dem Wohnzimmer
welches verwüstet ist nehmen Sie uns
gerne mal mit zeigen sie uns gerne was
passiert ist und vor allen Dingen wie
soll es jetzt auch für Sie in diesem
Winter der ja bevorsteht weitergehen
also quasi habe ich jetzt hier gesessen
das sind es quasi vielleicht zwei Meter
vom Kamin und links und rechts
sieht man
hier dieses Eisenteil das ist quasi
neben mir eingeschlagen und die
dazugehörige Tür die liegt hinter dem
hinter dem Sofa also ein Meter oder
vielleicht 50 cm weiter links und rechts
wäre es passiert wir können gerne mal
nach oben gehen ich gehe mal voraus
es hat wirklich dramatische Bilder
herbeige die wir hier aus ihrem Haus
sehen nach diesem nach dieser
kaminexplosion jetzt sind wir oben im
ersten Stock angekommen
hier sehen Sie die Rollade die aus der
Ankunft verrissen worden ist
und jetzt gehen wir mal in das zweite
Badezimmer da geht auch der Kamin
entlang
das hat auch die erste Etage
so wie sie sehen auch die erste Etage
hat halt auch die Druckwelle hier oben
erreicht
herbeige das muss ja auch unglaublich
laut gewesen sein was war das für ein
Knall für eine Druckwelle
also es waren sehr sehr dumm verknallt
so weil ich mich erinnern kann das war
ein Knall da war auch schon alles vorbei
das ganze Wohnzimmer war vernebelt dann
konnte die Hand vor Augen nicht sehen
und hier sehen sie fängt das schon an
mit dem ersten rissen
und das ist jetzt die dritte Etage wo
wir unser Elternschlafzimmer haben und
das auch der Kamin wie Sie sehen auch
explodiert und in unserem Ankleidezimmer
nicht gesprochen habe was durch die
Druckwelle
auch ausgerissen worden ist
das wurde dann halt erstmal
provisorisch von der Feuerwehr
abgedichtet sozusagen
ja hier sehen sie auch oben an den
Wänden
die richtigen ist also die Fenster sind
noch oben alle nach außen gedrückt
worden dass man wahrscheinlich erst noch
mal wissen es wirklich nicht was mit dem
Dach ist
herbeige gibt es schon Schätzungen wie
hoch der Schaden in ihrem Haus sein wird
nein also das ist alles noch offen von
der Kriminalpolizei aber auch nichts
gehört die waren auch direkt am Sonntag
vor Ort da und müssen wir jetzt abwarten
heute kommt ein Sachverständiger von
meiner Versicherung um unsere Stellen
erstmal aufzunehmen
und wie auch das jetzt alles doch so
tief also wir wissen es auch gar nicht
wie das weitergeht dann gehen wir uns
wenden müssen wir jetzt dafür
verantwortlich ist auch von Arbeit
anfangen können also wir sind also noch
richtig in ja wir sind von der Schwebe
wissen nicht wie es weitergeht ne und
wie gesagt deswegen sind erstmal froh
das war eine Last weniger haben wir sind
davon Freunden wir kennen uns schon von
klein auf an und das erste was er gesagt
hatten sie kommt sofort zu uns würde
sagen wir haben noch einen Hund und eine
Katze und der Hund den haben wir gleich
am selben Tag mitgenommen aber die Katze
mussten wir erst ein zwei Tage später
aber die gefunden ja aber dann irgendwo
unter dem Sofa unterm Schutt verängstigt
gefunden aber den beiden gibt es gut die
scheint es gut überstanden zu haben
meine Frau ist heute das erste mal
arbeiten gegangen und ich bleibe jetzt
noch für halt Sachen zwar gegen
Versicherung Polizei die ganz besonderen
also richtig in die Ruhe sind wir bis
jetzt nicht gekommen und ich weiß nicht
ob das noch später kommt
er schaut aber ich ja man funktioniert
einfach nicht es gibt jetzt einfach
weiter und so richtige Gedanken habe ich
mir noch gar nicht gemacht was hätte
passieren können komischerweise ich
nehme das so nichts passiert wäre aber
der Arzt weiter aus kann noch es kann
noch kommen das kann ein zwei Wochen
dauern bis man
zumindest körperlich geht es ihnen gut
Markus beige herzlichen Dank dass sie
ihre Geschichte mit uns geteilt haben
alles Gute für Sie und für ihre Familie
[Musik]